that holds grudges
bro grudges are garbage
yeah grudges are [ __ ] garbage
grudges are the execution of a weak man
one i think that a lot of people get
hurt
by the ideology of perfection so i think
one of the reasons long before i had
drock or a team
i was able to buy myself while running
businesses
be active on every platform
is because i didn't ideologically
think about every single piece of
content
i think when you're trying to make every
piece perfect for yourself
perfection is usually just another word
for insecurity
you know everyone's overthinking it and
so one it's to feel comfortable with
that number two
is
to
be okay with not being on six platforms
you know i think sometimes we feel too
much pressure to be everywhere i talk
about it like be everywhere post a lot
a lot of people can't manage that and
that's okay
i believe it has to do with
insecurity of success of the piece of
content
the biggest reason people didn't go to
tick tock when they were winning on
instagram was they didn't have the
humility and the self-confidence to not
be successful on tick-tock immediately
so i think the biggest reason people
don't produce
is more of a mental game then it's not
hard to produce content for six
platforms it's really not
you can do it
it's that people fear
lack of success in numbers from a vanity
standpoint which stopped them from
actually doing it
so i think humility
humility
is one of the true superpowers of a
scaled influencer or content creator
being okay with starting at zero or
being okay if the content's not doing
great
i'll give you another i mean for example
with me on tiktok even though i know
it's the most important platform i don't
have the time to produce original tick
tocks so i know my post-produced content
doesn't maximize my ability to win on
tick tock but i'd rather still put out
stuff and get what i can
than be insecure that i'm only getting
50 000 views on a tick tock when i have
13 million followers that doesn't
register to me as a negative for too
many people it does register as a
negative gary miguel bennett on director
of basketball here at stars prep uh
appreciate you um
can you give can you share with us with
these guys like the top
like your top three point of emphasis
for
having a
successful mindset i got you then and
this is clear for me because you know i
got gray hairs boys now like i've been
living it now i'm 46 now now i feel i
felt this at 16 but i know it at 46.
number one
accountability
this is gonna set you free whether it's
true or not in every situation
if you always know that it's always your
fault
it sounds crazy but that will keep you
crazy happy the amount of athletes i've
met that blame coaches even at the
professional level
blows my mind there are dudes in this
room who always are talking [ __ ] blaming
coach
right now
i see some of these good looking faces i
know behind that face i'm like that kid
right there you know like like it's real
do not blame anybody but yourself it
will make you happy it's a huge mindset
number two i am blown away by people's
entitlement just because your mom and
dad had sex at the right exact second to
give you athletic ability doesn't mean
nobody owes you [ __ ] so accountability
eliminating
first accountability second eliminating
entitlement nothing is owed to any of
y'all it is what it is it's like sports
it's a game
so just because somebody gave you a
scholarship or gave you an at-bat it's
you
you're not owed anything coach if you've
got real accountability like this is on
me and you don't think anybody else owes
you [ __ ] the last one is in a different
school but all together those three
change people's lives the third one is
simple which is be nice this is a crazy
one especially at this age if you
realize how life actually plays out and
you will one day when you're 60 70 80
the number one hack
the the smartest move
be kind which is why coach earlier i
said be nice to yourself because
nobody's nice to anybody else if they
don't like themselves the only people in
here that are mean trying to tear down
others because they're hurting when
people are tearing down other people
that just exposes that they're hurt but
if you're lucky enough to feeling good
give roses to people
because people are going to be the fuel
to get you there that's my mindset game
coach
some people don't maybe have the
disposition or perhaps they don't react
well to the kind of dopamine levels that
get released when you chase kind of
attention if you like on social media
what do you say to people who are kind
of struggling balancing that that long
before social media came along humans
struggled with that balance dopamines
have come in many forms including
interacting with other human beings this
narrative that is quite popular which is
blaming technology for your struggles is
a losing game i want to remind everybody
who's listening that only 30 years ago
we would blame the television we would
blame magazines showing models at 90
pounds as a bad force and all the things
we today try to point fingers towards
social media platforms which i want to
remind everybody are completely empty
vessels that human beings fill
information with is something that has
been historically true there was a time
and age that i could have sat in this
exact studio in the 1960s and you would
ask me questions of gary what do you say
about the situation where we have the
beatles and elvis disproportionately
impacting children and believing in this
rock and roll thing this is human
evolution we continue to be incredibly
infatuated with finding ways to point
fingers towards the current without
pointing thumbs to ourselves and leaning
into accountability and self-awareness
of how to deal with the macro and i
think i'm very empathetic to people's
concerns about the amount of time that
children and other humans spend on this
platform i want to remind people that
there is incredible good from those
things there are people who spend time
face timing their elders in different
countries because of technology and
social media so i think we're in the
current state where we're looking for
the shortcomings of the platform which
of course there are because human beings
have shortcomings
you think you can get talking to like
your college buddies
um like staying in touch with people who
are just like the average joe do you
think you can get perspective of them or
like a situation
you're having trouble in business or
you're trying to figure something out
and their like
idea or their like
input in it you think you could get like
perspective from people not connected
like that or on the outside that can
help you become a better person or a
better boss that's a great question i i
actually easily do i think it's
audacious and ludicrous for somebody who
has had professional success think that
like somebody that like
my brain works a little bit different i
don't think success is defined by your
bank account you don't mean miserable
millionaires i know
like to me i'm looking to be happy and
like i have unlimited
knowledge of people making less than
100k making less than 50k that are are
happy like i have buddies that i grew up
with that are like pumped making 80k a
year nice salary it's a nice salaries i
hate when people like 80 like the
world's [ __ ] up like 80k like if you
don't now if you don't if you live
within your means
but like by the way 80k comes with a lot
less pressure do you understand what my
life is i wake up i go right to my phone
offices in singapore offices and [ __ ]
you know in in mexico city i have 45 20
employees that are that are ukrainian
and russian do you understand what i'm
dealing with today like when you like
diddy and biggie that hold mo money more
problems that's real [ __ ] bro yeah like
like i don't envy being like i'm
actually upset that i'm an alpha one
i'd rather be a number four
yeah you know like i'm a [ __ ]
firefighter when i have to fill out the
[ __ ] you know immigration forms when
i go into other countries and they're
like occupation i literally write
firefighter
because when you're at the top of a
[ __ ] big company when you're doing
when you're out there the way i am where
everyone's gonna have opinions and
feelings on you you're just [ __ ]
taking
punches all day
look i i think you need to here's where
here's where i'm trying to get you to go
you need to get into a totally different
place with your self-esteem you need to
love yourself that's why the biggest
moment of this talk was you're not
negative you're just vulnerable that was
the biggest moment because when you wake
up and you're like i'm scared today
right and and i need to get less scared
today
that
is huge
huge compared to waking up and saying
i'm
negative
i'm a bad guy that's a game changer
alexis that's a game changer
yeah it's it's like hard though like i
try to i really really like there's a
lot of times where i'm like okay like
just stop thinking like that you know
like you got this
you have to understand it's ingrained in
you so what you need to do is practice
what do i mean by that
the next this one friend you've got
right now for a year the first time he
does something that doesn't pop off
properly you have to [ __ ]
you have to like email me or dm me or
watch this video game you have to
forgive him
right
yeah that's yeah
that holds
bro grudges are garbage yeah
grudges are [ __ ] garbage
grudges are the execution of a weakness
[Music]
you